- Hi, I'm Rashaan Evans.
I'm here to pick my all-time
Chiefs and 49ers lineup.
(Hip-hop music)
My first pick has gotta be
my guy Tyreek Hill right here.
One of the fastest players in the league
gotta go with Tyreek for first pick.
My second pick was...
obviously the great Patrick Willis.
One of the great
linebackers in the league.
Hall of Famer.
Now to spend three.
All right.
My third pick, I picked Patrick Mahomes.
Cuz I needed a great quarterback.
Gotta have a quarterback with a good arm
that can get it to my
receivers like Tyreek, so——
My fourth one, I had to go with...
I had to go with Derrick Thomas.
'Bama guy, Roll Tide.
So, one of the best pass-rushers
to do it, man. Rest in peace to him.
I'm goin', oh yeah, we
went with Tony Gonzalez.
For the three, for my last one.
OK, so right here my first pick
was obviously Tyreek Hill.
One of the fastest players, I feel like,
in the history of the
National Football League.
Just because of his, you
know, world-class speed.
Hopefully, he goes into the Olympics
or whatever he wants to do with that.
My second pick was Patrick Willis.
Obviously, I play inside linebacker,
one of the greats,
one of the guys that I looked at on film.
You know, just on how to play
the inside linebacker position.
My third pick was Patrick Mahomes.
I really needed an elite quarterback
to be able to get the
ball to my receivers
and a guy that can win football games.
My fourth pick was Derrick Thomas.
Obviously, a Roll Tide guy.
Was one of the best pass-rushers
to come through Alabama.
Rest in peace to him.
And last but not least, my fifth guy.
Another Hall of Famer, Tony Gonzalez,
who put up crazy numbers, probably one
of the greatest tight ends
to ever play the game.
So, this is my squad right here.
I feel like my squad is the best
just because of the, just the uniqueness.
I feel like a lot of
these guys mindset-wise
they just, they know how to win.
And they know how to get the job done.
They play with a mentality
of that, they don't care who it is.
They're gonna kick butt, so.
I would say this is the reason
why my squad is probably
the best right now, yeah.
Once again, this is Rashaan Evans.
I'm signin' out.
And here you go, I built my squad.
(Hip-hop music)